avec un peu de douceur bonjour casimir
avec beaucoup de couleurs
je voudrais saluer les gens sont
charmants mais il pourrait quand même de
dire bonjour à la dame à mon papa à
casimir tu nous entends quelqu'un m'a
père casimir redescend sur terre
bon vous êtes soir tous les deux casimir
mais il ya cinq minutes que du tourne
autour de nous et tu ne nous était pas
non je pensais à autre chose tu rêvais
tu étais dans la lune oui la lune
ça veut dire être distrait mennour
j'étais pas dans la lune puisque jetés
ici
malheureusement non merci tu es avec
nous ça devrait te faire plaisir
oui mais voyez vous il ya certains jours
où j'aimerais voir des têtes nouvelles
j'aimerais dire voir pierrot et
colombine par exemple eh bien en
attendant casimir tu vas aller faire les
courses
julie tu as le panier risque voilà la
liste des courses et casimir en chemin
tu aura peut-être une surprise j'en ris
de rêve et on m'envoie faire les courses
off un mois françois oui qu'est ce que
c'est que cette surprise que tu lui
réserve
mon génie mais tu n'as pas deviner mais
pierrot et colombine voyons allons-nous
déguisé
[Musique]
oh
attention j'ai dit pardon colombine
voici casimir
je suis prête pierrot au casino enfin
alors pierrot et colombine au but je
rêve pas du tout cas 6023 pour vérifier
je ne rêve pas que c'est aussi bois
confrères de foot moulard où le petit
nuage qui nous sert de taxi s'est posée
là où il a pu france a alors c'est
merveilleux voyage est sur un nuage
oui mais parfois il se transforme en
pluie vous savez je suis très content
vous voir france willy sont bien gentils
mais il manque parfois un peu de finesse
pour moi il manque un peu de finesse
oui je suis un délicat
remarquez ils sont braves trois fois
avant les ballons julie des bonbons qui
est bien content de manger quasi plus
aujourd'hui je suis complètement
détachée des choses matérielles et que
sais tu avec ce panier vide
bonjour et françois m'ont envoyé faire
des courses mais je n'y suis pas allé tu
veut peut-être faire quelque chose qui
sorte de l'ordinaire
oui exactement comme par exemple
rencontrer les personnages imaginaires
comme vous ça c'est extraordinaire
kazmir nous allons remplir son panier
avec des provisions de ré je veux bien
ça me changera d'aller acheter toujours
les mêmes choses
je n'aime pas regarder la geste est
d'ailleurs qui aurait peut-être dû
kazemi of je vais te donner un morceau
du bleu qui sert à colorer le ciel
rangez vous bien d'eux qu'ils ont
colombine je vais te les pesées il y en
a un peu plus on s'en ira
merci bien colombine cuisinière viens je
vais te donner du verre de la mère quand
elle se met gentiment en croit qu aucun
euro
il est un petit peu plus ça ira
c'est curieux ça fait toujours un peu
plus jamais un peu moins fais-tu le
champ de cette maison paroli chante dans
les arbres voilà la gamme tout entière
qui s'est mis bien merci
combien revoir ne rien du tout que
j'aimais tant merci nous suffit or c'est
formidable parce que avec françois et
les jurys ça fait toujours de frein et
bien voilà casimir ton panier est rempli
et nous devons partir maintenant comment
déjà hélas oui le petit nuage taxi et un
stationnement interdit sois gentil
casimir ne nous regarde pas partie quand
vous avez raison ce serait trop triste
au revoir pierrot revoir colombine voir
casey mai
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
où
oui oui
attention voilà vite alors quasiment tu
as bien fait les courses
oui j'ai même fait une provision de rêve
entre nous ça voilà un peu de bleu du
ciel un peu de vert de la mer et le
chant d'une mésange mais quasi mais nous
ne voyons rien et nous n'entendons rien
en plus décidément pierrot et colombine
ont plus d'imagination que tu as fais
les courses qu'ils avaient sur la liste
non j'ai même pas regardé la liste as tu
aurais peut-être dû casimir
tiens c'est curieux pierre on m'avait
dit la même chose maintenant tu pourrais
dire la liste
bon enfin si ça peut vous faire plaisir
des bananes des saucisses de toulouse de
la moutarde le chocolat et de la
confiture de fraises mec mais c'est tout
ce qu'il faut pour préparer un bon gros
bulgares alors je n'aurai rien pour mon
dîner mais c'est casimir du rêve et
c'est déjà pas si mal
bon
to be